So you all recall from our discussion on Monday,
we were,
we were working our way through nozicks hypothetic call a social contract story.
The thought experiment he asks us to engage in as a way of thinking about the
um,
social contract idea as a basis for political legitimacy.
And he asks us in effect to suspend disbelief and work through this story with
him holding out the promise that he's going to show how,
um,
the state can be legitimate.
And so he said,
imagine a hypothetical state of nature,
not consisting of pre political people,
but of people like you and me in a condition where there was no god ferment.
And we would find that to be very inconvenient and inefficient because as locked
said,
every single person would have to be an enforcer of the law of nature.
Everybody would have to look after their own property.
Um,
it'd be highly inefficient.
That in turn would lead to the creation of kind of block watch associations,
mutual protective associations.
They would also though not be particularly efficient because we all know from
reading Adam Smith that the thing that I'm really increases efficiency as
division of labor.
And so some people would go into the protection business in south protection,
um,
full time.
Um,
but because coercive force is a natural monopoly and we know from the discussion
last time Nozick agrees with Glenn back that it's the only natural monopoly.
Um,
eventually one of these groups would become dominant.
and that he calls the,
he,
one of his slogans is that's the ultra minimal state.
Now I did,
I will just pause here.
You might say,
well,
if that was true,
if coercive force is a natural monopoly,
why don't we have a world government?
I mean if we went from,
you know,
malicious to nations,
why aren't nations just malicious in the world
stands to reason,
right?
It's the same.
It just the same thing on a bigger scale.
Anyone wonder what Nozick might say?
Anyone got any idea what Nozick might say in response to that?
Okay.
Otherwise,
it doesn't seem very,
that you either either either coerce or force is a natural monopoly or it isn't.
No.
My missing something here.
What would,
what might Nozick say?
He doesn't confront this.
It's not anywhere in the book,
but it seems like a natural question to ask you now.
No.
Anyone want to try this?
Yeah.
Uh,
he might argue that because of kind of natural boundaries or even artificial
boundaries,
they have been created that the two societies or protection agencies are sort of
separated.
Yeah.
Brilliant.
I think you hit the nail on the head.
I think he would say it's conditioned by available technologies of force.
So,
mmm.
You know,
uh,
if it becomes possible
to project force all over the world,
um,
then we might get to the situation where we will have a world government that
indeed countries are just like bigger,
malicious within a country.
Um,
and if there were the available coercive force to create a world government,
uh,
it would be done.
Um,
the famous pacifist philosopher,
Bertrand Russell had a kind of no Ziki and view of this in,
uh,
he had opposed,
world war two.
He had opposed to creation of Nutria,
uh,
weapons.
But as soon as we dropped the bomb on Hiroshima in 1947,
Russell came out and said America should immediately declare a world government.
So he was no Ziki and in his thinking,
um,
but what he lacked was the knowledge of a social scientist.
He brought the clearheaded mess of a philosopher,
but that it wasn't constrained by the,
the knowledge of a social scientist.
Um,
because the mirror,
the mere fact that you have the capacity to destroy the world doesn't mean you
have the capacity to enforce obedience on the ground.
This is the lesson we learned in Iraq after 2003,
yes,
we could obliterate the Iraqi army,
but that's something quite different from actually being able to enforce the
rule of law within Iraq on the ground.
Right.
And it turns out,
uh,
we'll go into this in more detail a bit later,
but there are,
although there is one respect in which coercive force is a natural monopoly in
that it's
mmm hmm.
It for it to be a good,
it has to be,
um,
uh,
it has to be enforced over,
over a given territory.
Otherwise you just have this sorta situations we were talking about on Monday.
Uh,
nonetheless,
there are a various economies of smallness in enforcement.
Um,
and see the community policing literature discovered this in urban contexts.
so it's not as simple as it looks,
but I think just from the point of view of what we need to,
uh,
complete the thought experiment here is that Nozick would indeed say that the
reason we don't have a world government is simply that the available available
technologies of coercion have not yet evolved.
And so,
you know,
when it,
when it takes Hannibal's elephants to get over the Alps there they are a natural
boundary in a way that they are not when you can lob missiles over the Alps.
And so we shouldn't think of,
um,
we should,
we should always think when he says a natural monopoly over a given territory to
some extent,
what counts as a given territory is going to be affected by available technology
as a force.
And we could play this out.
You know,
if you think about the transition from the Italian city states to modern Italy,
there was a version of that.
The changing technology is a force leads to the creation of larger units.
But you know,
as,
as the points I've just made suggest,
this isn't entirely straightforward and uniform,
but it is one basic dynamics.
So that's,
I think what he would have said if somebody had raised that question.
Um,
and so you get a single dominant protective association within a given
territory,
although we agreeing that the notion of what counts as a territory is somewhat
in flux and conditioned by technology is a force.
That's the,
um,
the dominant protective association is,
has cooperated or marginalized all the others.
And then you have a dominant protective association.
Each she calls the ultra minimal state.
Um,
but then there are these people,
these independence.
And he gives various colorful examples of them.
But as I said,
this was 1974.
Uh,
if we think about it in today's world,
you can think about these as people who don't recognize the legitimacy of the
regime.
So they could be people like,
um,
the gen tooth flew his plane into a federal building in wherever it was,
Texas,
I think a couple of weeks ago,
I could be,
um,
Timothy Mcveigh who blew up the Oklahoma federal bed building,
or it could be Osama bin Ladin.
These people are out there and they say,
well,
you might have your dominant protective association,
but we don't care because we don't like it.
We don't recognize it and we are not part of it.
Okay.
And Nozick wants to say,
well,
just because coerce or force is a natural monopoly,
these protective associations can't give members protection if they allow the
Osama bin Ladin send the Timothy Mcveigh's to run around out there.
So what did they gonna do?
They're gonna force them to accept the authority of the state.
They're going to force them to participate.
They're going to say,
this is the Dale take it and you can be part of the association or leave it and
you're going to be dealt with accordingly.
We're going to lock you up.
We're going to kill you.
We're going to do something to you.
Right.
That's what's going to happen because of the night that,
because it's the case that these associations cannot protect their members it if
they don't do anything else.
I'm going to come back to that in a minute.
So it's just at this level,
it's just a claim about what would happen,
coercive force being what it is,
and then you have what he calls the minimal state,
Aka the classical nightwatchman state of liberal theory.
The thing that Glenn back has in mind when he says,
the government should protect us from the bad guys and nothing else.
The government should protect us from the bad guys and nothing else.
The night watchman state doesn't do anything else in particular.
It does not redistribute wealth.
There's not redistribute income and wealth.
It does not go into those parades.
Undecidable zones.
Think back to the parade oh diagram.
And the reason it doesn't go back to those Paredo undecidable zones is that we
have a very strobus doctrine of individual rights right now.
You might say,
well,
why should we buy that?
And I think what Nozick would say is
he would come back with the doctrine of deep pluralism.
Our values,
there's deep pluralism of values.
We don't agree.
You know,
some of us think we should have a welfare state.
Some of us think we shut him,
some of us think we should have universal healthcare.
Some of us don't.
We don't agree about these things.
And because we don't agree about these things,
this dark kind of be the pressure to produce a redistributive state.
We're gonna,
we're going to look at it.
You know,
one of his slogans is rights as side constraints on our actions.
We think of rights as site constraints on what we can do to are the people we
can't,
you know,
elbow them as we go on our way to maximize our own utility rights aside
constraints then not,
um,
and,
and states they're not goals.
So,
um,
hm.
I don't want to
give you on unnecessary jargon,
but I guess I'll give it to you anyway.
I should have put it on a slide.
So,
um,
th the,
the philosophical lingo for the difference between Nozick and Rawls,
as we'll see later on the one hand
and utilitarianism,
at least in Benson experience on the other hand is day ontological versus t
teleological,
d e o n t.
O logical.
They on tautological versus teleological,
t e l e O.
Logical.
And what,
what he's trying,
what is captured day?
Ontological is a word that comes from the philosopher Emmanuel Kant.
We'll talk more about him in connection with roles I mentioned to you on Monday
the eye.
The basic notion here is affirm principles that you can,
if you,
that you would be happy with no matter how they affected you.
Then not hypothetical imperatives.
They're not,
you know,
I'll support private profit.
If it makes me rich,
they'll,
they're rare.
The,
if,
if I support private property Algebra,
support it regardless of whether it makes me rich or poor.
Right?
Uh,
it's not dependent on any particular empirical conditions.
You would affirm it no matter what.
And Can'ts famous example of a categorical imperative is the thing Nozick a PLC
to respect people's autonomy.
Don't treat them simply as means to round bought as ends in themselves.
Okay?
And he's saying,
well,
if we want to respect people's autonomy,
this is just a very strong version of mill's harm principle.
We want to respect people's autonomy.
We can't impose conditions on them that they don't agree with.
Okay?
And given that people,
given this empirical fact of deep pluralism,
a values,
you're not going to get a redistributive state out of my Robert Nozick little
story.
So that's where it's going to stop.
No,
you could say,
okay,
what have we really,
what is really being established here?
Why is Nozick walking us through this zigzag?
You know,
I mean,
it's okay.
It's one way to spend,
uh,
a Monday,
Wednesday morning between 10 30 and 1130.
But what is the,
what is the point?
What really comes out of this?
You know,
what is,
what is going,
why is he doing this?
Okay?
And I think that we should,
we need to go back through it a little bit more carefully now and see,
one of the things that he says is he's,
he's telling us both
an explanatory story and a normative story.
What I said here is basically the explanatory story you saying.
If you took people like us and you said what would happen if there was in a
state,
they would create a minimal state and they wouldn't create anything more.
That's just an,
it's a,
there's not nothing normative in that yet.
At least not obviously.
So they would create,
um,
you know,
Glenn backs Utopia and that's all that they would do.
We could argue about whether or not he's right about that.
And I'll come back to that in,
in,
in a minute,
but,
but that's not really nozicks whole agenda.
His real agenda is normative.
What he wants to say is they would do this and this is the only legitimate
state.
That's what he really,
when he wants to convince you that this,
this kind of a state than the classical nightwatchman state of liberal theory,
liberal in the 19th century were sense of the term,
right?
Libertarian,
we might think of it,
I think today is the only legitimate stake.
Now,
if you said,
well,
why,
what makes it legitimate?
The answer is that long and rather difficult to decipher a chapter on
compensation.
And let me,
I'll just,
I'll give you the bumper sticker version first and then I'll go back and walk
through it.
And you might think it's tendentious,
but um,
okay.
You know,
philosophers,
examples often give philosophy a bad name.
They create highly artificial examples,
um,
that abstract massively from the real world.
And people,
um,
generally are not impressed when,
uh,
they try to connect it to real problems.
I,
I'm,
you know,
my priors to be suspicious of philosophy as examples,
but Nozick is an exception.
He really was a brilliant guy and he doesn't do these things gratuitously.
There's some interesting,
uh,
and consequential points that come out of this.
So here's what he wants to say.
Okay.
This is the,
the,
the shawl set of moves.
This one and this one.
How,
how,
how is it crucial?
What he wants to say is this,
we know that this is going to happen.
What could make it legitimate?
We know it's going to happen because coerce or force is a natural monopoly.
In fact,
being hardheaded realists about power,
no minimals or ultra minimal state is going to permit the bin Laden's and then
make veys to run around threatening them.
So they got to force them to join.
What could make it legitimate for them to do that?
Since these independents haven't agreed to join,
right?
And Nozick does one is say agreement.
Consent is the basis of all legitimacy.
Seems like a contradiction.
So he says,
what if
we'd say we,
we put it in the following terms.
What if we say
to the independent out there,
you know what,
you don't recognize the legitimacy about operation,
but it's too bad because there's a lot more of us than there are of you and
we're going to force you to,
we're going to force you to participate.
But here's the thing,
we,
we understand that violates your rights.
You as an independent or having your rights violated.
But we as members are having our rights violated by our fear that you
may blow us up.
Maybe one,
maybe you're just a philosophical Attica said,
one is around the fields talking to horses and wants to be left alone.
But we now know that for sure.
You know,
we don't really know that.
And you know,
there are some people who want to blow us up out there.
We know that.
So everybody in our society,
in our ultra minimal state is,
is experiencing a decline of utility because you're out there and you might blow
us up.
We are experiencing fear.
Now we understand that you,
if you're forced to join,
are going to lose.
You're going to experience a rights violation.
That's true.
But what if we could compensate you for it?
We're going to force you to join.
What if we could compensate you for it and still be better off then we were
not having compensated you and experiencing the fear.
So everybody gets,
it's somewhat muddled discussion in the chapter when people start reading,
he already says about compensation.
They think he's talking about um,
the members being compensated rather than the independence.
But the idea is the members could compensate the independence and still be
better off.
Now it doesn't mean the members actually compensate the independence,
then there would be an obvious moral hazard problem,
right?
If,
if my choice was to be a member and pay taxes or to be an independent and get
compensated for being forced to join and nobody's going to be a member,
we might as well be independence and get caught.
So he's not talking about actual compensation.
Okay.
Rather he's saying
if in principle,
so I'm going to violate your rights.
If in principle I could pay you enough to make you whole and still be better off
than before I violated your rights,
then everything's Hunky Dory.
We're both better off in a parade.
Oh cents.
Okay.
So what he does in that chapter,
as he works his way through various ways,
this might happen and they all all
fail,
they'll run into problems.
How would you figure the price,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Right?
And then he says,
well,
it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't really matter that I haven't given an a watertight account of
compensation,
but just let's assume that some such account could be given,
then we'd have solved the problem.
And he,
and he's alluding here to about 40 years of welfare economics that,
um,
revolve around this idea of Co hypothetical compensation tests.
Those of you who are interested,
the famous people were caldor Hicks,
Guitar Ski Samuelsson and many others.
Um,
all we're trying to figure out a compensation test that was compatible with the
parade.
Oh system as you know it.
So why of thinking about it is we go back to a parade oh diagram.
And what we were doing when we are talking about neoclassical utilitarianism,
remember we said,
um,
let's suppose x is the status quo.
We know this is Pareto superior.
We know this is parade.
Oh,
inferior.
And we can't say anything about the parade are undecidable.
Right.
So the question is,
yeah,
is why better than x for society?
There's no answer to that question and nozicks endorsing that,
right?
He's saying,
you know,
be will think why it's better.
A,
we'll think x is better.
Who are we to adjudicate between them?
There's no way to do it.
But the,
the people who are worrying about compensation with thinking about a different
question,
they were saying,
well,
okay,
we can't say we know.
We can't say that.
Why is better than x for society?
But couldn't we say thatZ is better than x?
Because althoughZ is,
oh,
those z is Paredo undecidable
it's on the possibility frontier remmber the possibility frontier was the,
the locus of points where it's not possible to improve.
Right.
So the compensation period theorists were actually interested in these two
parts of the parade.
Oh,
diagram.
There were saying,
isn't there?
Can't we come up with some way to say thatZ is,
is a social improvement on x,
even though it's per undecidable because it's on the possibility frontier.
Isn't there some way to say if you move from off the possibility frontier to on
the possibility frontier,
you can say it's a social improvement.
So in the Lingo of welfare economics,
that was the project from caldor and Hicks,
Kotowski Samuelson and all of the others.
They were looking for a way to do that that did not involve into personal
comparisons of utility.
Really important that it not involve interpersonal comparisons of utility.
Okay.
Because if you make into personal comparisons of utility,
you've,
you're violating consent,
right?
If you,
if you say,
wow,
Z is better than x,
but beat us and agree,
I mean a doesn't agree,
you're violating A's.
Right?
So is there some way to do that?
You know,
and we see this all the time in eminent domain cases,
you know,
when the city buys a property forcibly against somebody as well,
uh,
to build a road,
this,
you know,
endless toing and froing about what is the value of the house.
Um,
and,
and the question is,
can you figure that out without doing interpersonal comparisons of you tell him.
And
the problem with what Nozick is doing is that the answer is no.
The answer is every compensation test that's ever been devised involves coming
up with a common metric,
namely money in terms of which you do the compensation.
And because of that,
you're implicitly making interpersonal comparisons of utility.
So the,
the project of
finding a compensation test that didn't violate the interpersonal comparisons
criterion failed.
And you can't actually do what Nozick wanted us to do.
Now you could say,
okay,
so here's again an example of the kind of whole architect tonic theory doesn't
work,
but there still might be important insights that survive.
It's
fail.
Yeah.
So you could say,
for instance,
okay,
once we,
once we're aware of that,
mmm.
We,
we can say that there,
that even in the creation of a minimal state,
there are some interpersonal comparisons of utility,
namely those involved in judging whether or not it's legitimate to incorporate
the independence
and Nozick might make the following defense of what he's done.
He's,
he might say,
wow,
okay.
You know,
it was a nice try,
but still what's left of my argument is the following.
MMM.
And now the Kantian dictum is ord and tails.
Can
anyone want to tell us about that mean or what and what does it mean to say what
entail scamp
anyone know
and we say what entails,
can anyone,
anyone want to guess?
Yeah.
The normative statements that we may make me create bright lines by which we can
determine whether an action is or is not acceptable.
And that's like by saying that we should or should not do something.
We create this bright line where
on one side we should and side we uh,
yeah,
you're in the right direction.
You're making it more complicated than it needs to be.
I mean,
the basic idea is we can't have a moral obligation to do something that's
impossible.
We can't have a moral obligation to do something that's impossible.
That's the,
that's the way in which ord entails.
Can,
is usually interpreted.
Now some people say we should an interpret that way we should interpret comment
to mean when he says what entails can that if we ought to do something,
we should find a way.
I once had a graduate student wrote a dissertation in which he said or entails,
can means that ord entails,
must try as hard as possible.
Well,
you know that,
that that's that's uh,
that's one way you could go with this,
but it's not what I have in mind here.
What I have in mind here that that knows it.
I think would say when confronted with the failure of the compensation tests to
work without interpersonal comparisons,
I think Nozick would say,
well
or didn't entails,
can in the conventional sense,
we can't expect people to do something that's impossible and for that reason.
Okay.
What drives this really is the natural monopoly of force argument.
Another way you could see this,
you could say,
well,
so
yeah,
the problem with the compensation argument compensating the independence is we
could equally say if the company,
if the independence could compensate the members for their fear and still be
better off,
that would be just as good.
Yeah.
Right.
Nozick saying the members experience the fear,
they forced the con the,
the independence to join.
And if they could compensate them and still be as well off,
then it's legitimate.
But you could do the exact opposite.
You could say if the,
if the independence could compensate everybody,
pay everybody aside an amount so that they stop experiencing fear,
um,
and still be better off,
you know,
in,
in effect,
Osama bin Laden did this when they made it,
when he alcaide he made a deal in the 1980s,
uh,
they promised the Saudis they wouldn't,
they would,
they promised the Saudis that they wouldn't,
mmm,
do I need terrorism in Saudi Arabia?
And then the Saudis left them.
The Saudi government left them alone.
I mean,
that,
that eventually unravel.
But so essentially you could say that was a version of compensating the Saudi
population for the fear and still being better off.
So Nozick would have to be indifferent between those two things,
right.
If,
if it's all that striving at is the compensation.
I think what he would say is while in principle,
yes,
but in practice because of the natural monopoly of force,
um,
it's the independence who are going to lose the independence,
we're going to lose.
There's fewer of them.
Right.
And in the end,
the event just pursuing this example in the event since both the Saudis and
everybody else knew that Alcaide,
his ultimate objective is regime change in Saudi Arabia.
I wasn't a very credible promise and indeed,
uh,
eventually,
and indeed there were Al Alcaide operations in Saudi Arabia in the late 1990s.
So it wasn't a very credible promise.
And,
uh,
eventually after nine 11,
the Saudis,
um,
smelled the coffee and got on board with the operation to try and stomp out al
Qaeda.
Okay.
So yes,
in principle,
if the independence could compensate blahbity Blah and just be as well off,
we would be indifferent in practice because of the natural monopoly of force,
the independence are going to lose.
So ordered tails can,
it's not possible.
It's not possible to imagine a state of affairs in which the independence of
tolerated.
So we'll accept that.
That is legitimate.
It.
In other words,
the,
the violation of rights is unavoidable.
Uh,
and therefore it's not a legitimate,
um,
that would be the claim.
Now,
Nozick would then say,
so my arguments of vibes,
my argument survives because of we've now supplemented the natural monopoly of
force with ord entails scan.
Um,
there's no way not to have the ultra minimal state become the minimal state.
So I can't,
it's legitimacy can't be criticized for that particular,
for the violation of the rights of the Independent.
In a way,
it's a bit reminiscent of Locke's argument about majority rule that we're going
to talk about when we get to the last part of the course in more detail.
What you know already about lock from what I've told you in the past,
is that Locke says,
when there are disagreements about what natural law in tails,
there's no earthly authority who's allowed to settle them.
Remember,
we went through this,
right?
So each person in effect has the right to enforce the law of nature and indeed
the responsibility to enforce the law of nature.
God speaks to us all individually when we read the scriptures.
And if you're worried him one way,
and I read him the other way,
there's no pope,
there's no king,
there's no magistrate who can tell us who is right.
Okay.
It's one of the sources of locks.
Egalitarianism.
What another thing that Locke says that I haven't talked about yet by we'll get
into in more detail,
is so what actually happens in practice when people disagree.
He says,
if you think,
if you think
the state is violating natural law,
not only do you have a right,
you actually have an obligation to resist,
but if nobody else agrees with you,
what's going to happen?
You're going to be out of luck,
right?
As lockbox.
You,
you,
you should look for your,
he,
no,
he says you'll,
you should look for your reward in heaven,
I.
E you'll be,
you know,
if,
if I,
if you take the view that the government is not legitimate and you're going to
resist it and nobody else agrees with you,
you're going to wind up being tried for treason and executed.
That's what's going to happen.
But this life is short.
Have an x,
y,
and Z.
Turnell.
So why worry,
right?
Uh,
is essentially Locke's view of the matter,
right?
Um,
so the no Ziki and independent is in the same position as a lock.
He in person who,
who reads the scripture to say that they must resist the state and,
and very few others agree with them.
They just,
you know,
gonna get their reward in the next life,
so be it.
Um,
but if lots of people agree with you,
then you're going to have 60,
98,
then you're going to have a revolution.
You're going to get rid of the monarch,
right?
So you can't know for sure that people don't agree with you,
but that's what's going to happen.
And in a way that that is exactly the same point Nozick is making.
He's saying,
you know,
there are a lot more people in the ultimate animal state then there are in the
independent.
So it's gonna go that way.
There it is.
It's a nature of power.
The nature of coerce or force an ort entails can mango,
what about that?
How many people find that convincing?
Nobody.
Nobody's came is how many people find it on campus.
How about it?
This t two,
two zero convinced to I'm convinced and are 136 on decided like Massachusetts
voters here.
Paul,
what's,
what's wrong with it?
Anyone want to,
well,
it seems that forcing the independence to,
you know,
submit to the minimalist state directly contradicts the pluralistic,
um,
Dan theological values that it's espousing.
So it like undermines the State Ed.
It's very
okay.
And um,
what does it contradict which the value of consent,
excuse me,
you say it directly contradicts the intellectual values he's espousing,
which value?
The value of consent.
Yeah,
the value of,
um,
consent and how you said,
uh,
it should be minimalist because he believes in pluralism and because um,
you can't like force someone and you don't,
you like the Predo thing,
you don't know.
Right.
But,
but his answer is Orin pals can,
you know,
it would be lovely if we could get everybody's consent,
but there's no way to get everybody's consent.
Well.
Then from that follows that they should be,
the government should be able to enact like other kinds of policies where our
main tail can and they can force people to do things.
So what would,
what would be an example?
They would have to just tolerate these independents out there?
Yeah.
All right.
I think there's a,
there's a,
I use,
there's a little book I used to teach in this course sometimes by a philosopher
called Robert Paul Wolf called in defense of Antica some and he basically goes
the way you were going.
He says,
he says,
consent is,
is a wellspring of legitimacy.
You can't get unanimous consent for any steak,
so no status,
legitimate
Lacy's consistent.
Right.
You can't yet
legitimacy for any states or no status.
Legitimate while states I on at genomic finished end of story.
Yeah.
Yes.
I think what Nozick would say,
he would make two points.
He would say Robert Paul Wolff is an airhead because
he's forgetting about the difference between
the philosophical game.
We're playing the the thought experiment and the real world because in the real
world there are two things that are different.
One is the natural monopoly of force argument we've already talked about and uh,
ordered entails,
can limitation that puts on what's possible.
But the other,
and you might not buy that cause you,
you might,
you might say if we had time to go back and forth,
you might just say,
I just know him by that states could protect themselves from um,
independence without wiping out the independence.
They could,
you know,
have policies of containment.
I even wrote a book about that so you could,
we could go back and forth about that.
Um,
but I think the other thing that,
that Nozick might say two to Robert Paul Wolff is this,
it,
they involve buying the critique of the social contract metaphor.
He would say,
well,
we're behaving as though not having collective action is really an option.
But it isn't because
it's always the case that we have some collective action regime.
Just question is just which one.
So
in any given situation,
if you require unanimity,
you privilege the status quo.
We know that,
right?
The garbage in,
garbage out problem.
And
if some people want to have a state and some people don't want to have a state.
If you start with a state,
then requiring unanimity to change,
it harms the people who don't want to state.
But if you start without a state and requiring unanimity to change it,
it harms the people where the state.
So in either case you're going to be harming somebody writes a violating
somebody's rights.
So
the bottom line is that anarchy,
even if it existed,
if we,
if we had Anna chasm,
what didn't meet Wolf's criterion
of respecting everybody's
autonomy,
because there would be some people who didn't want that.
Okay,
I'm going to,
we got two minutes left,
so I'm going to leave you
with it.
What's the beginning of a deep,
a puzzle about Nozick that will,
uh,
pick up on Monday with
you could say,
okay,
we'll grant it will grant everything you're saying.
No,
Zack.
But then
what if
people start to say,
okay,
we're not minimal state,
you know,
but a lot of us are afraid of unemployment.
We see recessions come and go.
Or employment can suddenly shoot up to 10% I could lose every,
I could lose my job,
not be able to pay my mortgage.
That fair.
That fear reduces a lot about utility.
So
we're going to create unemployment insurance
and some people don't like it.
Some people would rather take the risk,
internalize their risk,
but you know what they were going to treat them.
And just the way you treat independence.
So we're going to say,
well we know you don't like funding on employment insurance.
You'd rather internalize the risk,
but you know what,
there are a lot more of us.
And then there are you and we,
we believe we could compensate you for the cost.
And in principle,
of course we don't compensate in practice.
We believe we could compensate you in principle for the rights violation of
forcing you.
Who doesn't want to pay for unemployment insurance to pay for an employment
insurance and still be better off.
So tough luck.
You're going to pay for unemployment insurance and then all of us will be
happier because we'll be back on us a higher indifference curve then when we
were,
uh,
worrying about what might happen if we lose our job.
And so the trouble with you nosy,
cause you're too clever for your own God because either your argument doesn't
establish enough where it's establishes too much.
Because if we give you this type of reasoning to get to the minimum state,
we can hijack exactly the same reasoning to get to the welfare state.
We can just put it in this idiom of compensation for fear
and we can justify a more extensive state then you want.
And so either your argument doesn't get you the minimum state or gets you too
much of a state.
Okay,
we'll start with that next time.